hallo ich bin's tennis welt er kennt die
kulisse hinter mir vielleicht hat sich
verändert ich bin nämlich grad in der
türkei in der ferienwohnung und mach mit
murat und samira bisschen urlaub meine
eltern sind auch hier ganz in der nähe
und es ist wirklich sehr schön und vor
allem warum also heute sonntag bei uns
und wir haben glaube ich gefühlte 50
grad
ich glaube es nur 35 und ich stets
gratis wie immer in der küche weil ich
kann auch hier nicht sein lassen und
macht ein leckeres rezept für euch und
hab gedacht ich mich jetzt einfach mal
ganz kurz mit einem video
also wie gesagt man mir gerade urlaub
und es hat sich bei uns jetzt ziemlich
viel ergeben und ich muß ich möchte mich
erst mal zuerst bei allen bedanken die
mir auf facebook folgen denn ich habe
mittlerweile seit gestern schon über
100.000 gefällt mir angaben was ziemlich
viel ist vor allem jetzt in letzter zeit
so stark gewachsen und auf youtube habe
ich jetzt schon fast 300.000 abonnenten
und ich finde es einfach wahnsinn als
ich weiß ein letztes jahr im august habe
ich die 100000 geknackt und war extrem
glücklich darüber weil ich einfach diese
dreistellige zahl an plötzlich da hatte
da war es irgendwann 200.000 die zins
schon über 270.000 es geht im moment
einfach extrem schnell und fällt so über
uns her aber ich freue mich total sowie
skat ist und wie es eben auch weiter
geht und weil mich da einfach bei euch
bedanken da beide videos fleißig
kommentiert und teilte euren freunden
und der familie davon erzählt also das
ist wirklich sehr schön ganz ganz
herzlichen dank
und ja man hat mich ja und jetzt
überlegt dass wir jetzt auch einen kanal
auf türkisch machen hatte ich schon
länger vor
aber ich habe mich also ich sag mal so
richtig getraut ich spreche zwar
türkisch aber deutlich hat doch
so die steigerung sprache sage ich jetzt
mal ich habe in deutschland meine
schulbildung aufgemacht und mineral
geboren und aufgewachsen aber als
gedacht wer trauer selbst machen dass ab
sommer wird dann auch türkische rezept
videos von mir geben und ich habe im
moment aktuell noch keinen namen dafür
aber vielleicht eine idee wie ich das
machen könnte auf jeden fall hätte ich
gerne irgendwas mit sally mit drin also
mit dem mit einem spitznamen und ja da
war ich ganz froh wenn ich mit ein paar
ideen aufzeigen
ein paar vorschläge genau ich mache
übrigens auch bald schwäbische video
okay ja und es weder was los sein also
nicht dass ihr euch nicht benachteiligt
fühlt es gibt alle rezepte im türkischen
macht gibt es natürlich auch im
deutschen
anders kann ich es nicht machen weil in
der türkei ist das problem
ich klicke hier einfach nicht alle
zutaten wie in deutschland also ich
stehe zum beispiel hier wird gern keine
ahnung quarkbällchen machen oder quark
uhren kanzler hat weil sie hat keinen
quark gibt also hier muss man dann
ausreichen auf stichfesten joghurt oder
auf frischkäse oder so mascarpone und es
gibt hier einfach nicht alles um das
heißt mein deutscher kanal meinen sallys
welt kanal hat weiterhin alle rezepte
und kriegt auch immer alle rezepte auch
der türkische kanal muss halt auf paar
rezepte verzichten weil es einfach nicht
geht und ich muss ist umschreiben
ja und wenn darüber legen nicht nur weil
es ist nicht hier ist alles so teuer wie
sich das problem 8
wie gesagt das eis gemacht und habe
dafür seien genutzt und ein becher sahne
kurs etwa um 200 gramm zu ungefähr wenn
man seine eigenmarken im format zur etwa
45 49 cent je nach dem grad enix preise
sind wahrscheinlich und in der türkei
zahl fast das vierfache seines vielfach
als ich mal knapp 5 lieber und es sind
ungefähr 1 80 also bis aufs gemüse ich
allerdings extrem ist ob sich extrem
ich aber alles andere extrem teuer
findet zum beispiel der teuer wenn ich
jetzt mal milchprodukte und fleisch
anschaue denke ich mir das muss auch so
einen gewissen preis haben vor allem
landwirtschaftlich gehalten wird aber
wenn ich mir zu überlegen leute hier
verdienen hat auch viel weniger als wie
in deutschland dann erst für die leute
schon sehr viel geld
fleisch ist doppelte fleischer stoffe zu
teuer und und soll aber gemüse oder obst
eine melone kurs zum beispiel 40 senders
was 13 also 13 cent kostet ein kilo 13
10 kilo waren echt total künstlich
deswegen ernähre ich mich hier am
liebsten sowieso vegetarisch oder vegan
sogar weil milchprodukte nimmt man etwa
außer dem frühstück
ja also da wir jetzt main kanal kommen
und aufsichtsrat nicht alle alles
weiterhin gleich mit einem videos und
ich glaube jetzt alles gesagt
damit gewinnspiel wo sich aus wenn ich
wieder zurück bin ja und grüß mir die
heimat
ich gucke ich komme halt ich hätte ich
komme wieder
genau wie komm bald wieder und die
videos mexiko wieder da und die videos
lassen sich im moment automatisch hoch
und ich mal meine facebook postet und so
weiter und bekommt natürlich weiterhin
mittwochs freitags und sonntags ein
video genau und wie machen wir die
typischen videos von meinen türkisch ist
gar nicht vorhanden da man das auch so
die werden dann auch im türkischen falls
er ausgestrahlt also nicht total kochen
kann meine mama auch immer gucken eine
türkische familie dass ich auf youtube
und wie man es dann kamera technisch
mache weiß ich nicht weil der murat er
spricht wirklich aber ich sag mal papa
spricht besser deutsch als demokratie
ist schlecht und das ist auf jeden fall
wird es dadurch auch lustig und ich
freue mich da
ich kümmere mich jetzt um ein eis und
danke euch wie gesagt nochmals ganz
herzlich für facebook instagram youtube
und das sehen wir immer alle ganz schön
voll kommentiert aber leben teilhaben
ich finde es wirklich super schön und
ich freue mich auf die nächste zeit mit
euch
bis dahin tschüss special effect
überrascht wir schenken uns nix ja cool
ich habe dem kind geschenkt so wichtig
war dabei